it's described as an addiction but
psychiatrists say the antidotes don't go
far enough
like most youngsters John bolts spent
most of his teenage years feeling
pressured to be part of the online world
he found batteries aren't the only thing
they drain it could be quite there like
a Mensa it's a mentally exhausting
experience you know if you see something
online where some perhaps someone is
struggling with their own mental
experiences and have used it now you
know as a way of expressing it or is
using it as a malicious tool that can be
quite damaging to you and I think that
has a real massive effect on your
well-being in real life not just online
it's this harm psychiatrists want to
stamp out there asking for social media
Giants to hand over our data so that
researchers can learn about how content
affects us social media companies got a
lot of knowledge they got very
sophisticated algorithms and what
happens is these young people have had
more and more of the same sort of
material which can then increase their
distress it was unregulated posts on
Instagram that led to 14-year old Molly
Russell taking her own life she was
found to viewed violent and harmful
images online her father says access to
this data could be invaluable we'd be
better informed so we could make better
decisions it's hard to make decisions as
a parent for the safety of your children
it was all too easy for someone like
Molly to be sucked into that world
particularly so because the platform's
algorithms would would once molly
started looking at their content post
ever more such content towards her so
she was consumed by sort of dark black
and suicidal means the government has
pledged to introduce a regulator with
the ability to find major tech companies
failing to show a duty of care but there
are some benefits to the sites
[Music]
when Jake Moses stepdad was diagnosed
with leukemia the fourteen-year-old
turned to social media to draw attention
to the issue what are some of the
benefits you've seen from communicating
with people online if I have one friends
that shares an awareness video for blood
cancer it ends up getting thousands of
views it really helps me with what I
want to tell people about blood cancer
and what we do as an organization
positive for some and destructive for
others social media is the gift of the
modern world that we're still learning
to live with but perhaps the
introduction of data sharing could be
the step needed to stop putting young
people at risk
Asha Hari Naik Sky News